la velocidad de una reacción química se
define como el cambio en la
concentración ya sea del reactivo o del
producto entre el cambio en el tiempo la
concentración se mide en moles por litro
o molares y el tiempo se mide en
segundos
entonces expresamos la velocidad de la
reacción en molares por segundo lo cual
se parece muchísimo a metros por segundo
cierto y si recordamos un poco de física
esto es la unidad de la velocidad
promedio ok y para sacar la velocidad
promedio lo que hacemos es medir el
cambio en x o sea la distancia recorrida
entre el cambio en el tiempo y bueno
pensar en la velocidad promedio ayuda
muchísimo para entender por qué
definimos a la velocidad de la reacción
de esta forma y lo que vamos a hacer
ahorita es calcular la velocidad de una
reacción realmente muy sencilla aunque
ahí tenemos un campo
a que a lo largo de la reacción se va a
convertir en un compuesto ver y digamos
que en el tiempo cero o sea al inicio de
la reacción tiempo cero la concentración
del compuesto a es de un molar y como
estamos al inicio de la reacción el
compuesto a todavía no se convierte en
el compuesto b entonces la concentración
de pepe es cero aunque haya el tiempo
cero que es el tiempo en el que inició
la reacción ahora digamos que esperamos
dos segundos y entonces estamos en el
tiempo igualados y volvemos a medir la
concentración de a y bueno sabemos que
la concentración de a va a disminuir
porque a se está convirtiendo en b
entonces digamos que la concentración de
a en esta medición es de 0.98 molar así
es que acabamos de perder una
concentración de 0.02 molar del
compuesto
y como en esta reacción hace
bien entonces después de dos segundos de
la reacción o sea al tiempo dos la
concentración debe tiene que ser 0.02
molar y ahora si queremos saber cuál es
la velocidad de reacción promedio
entonces lo único que tenemos que hacer
es poner estas cantidades que ya tenemos
de esta reacción en la fórmula de la
velocidad de reacción aunque tenemos que
poner el cambio en la concentración
entre el cambio en el tiempo
entonces la velocidad de la reacción es
igual al cambio en la concentración y
eso es concentración final menos
concentración inicial porque ponemos
concentración final 0.02 menos
concentración inicial o sea cero punto
cero
todo es el cambio en la concentración y
eso lo tenemos que dividir entre el
cambio en el tiempo o sea tiempo final
menos tiempo inicial el tiempo final es
22 menos el tiempo inicial que es 0
entonces la velocidad de la reacción es
0.2 entre 2 y eso pues es 0.01 molares
por segundo
acabamos de calcular la velocidad de
reacción promedio desde que el tiempo es
igual a 0 hasta que el tiempo es igual a
2 ahora aquí calculamos la velocidad de
la reacción utilizando las
concentraciones del producto pero de la
misma forma pudimos haber calculado la
velocidad de la reacción utilizando las
concentraciones del reactivo aunque en
lugar de definir a la velocidad de la
reacción como la velocidad con la que
aparece ve pudimos haber definido a la
velocidad de la reacción como la
velocidad con la que desaparece
entonces la velocidad de la reacción es
el cambio en las concentraciones de a
entre el cambio en el tiempo y el cambio
en la concentración de a es la
concentración final osea 0.98 menos la
concentración inicial o sea menos 1
y luego tenemos que dividir entre el
cambio en el tiempo o sea 2 - 0 tiempo
final menos tiempo inicial y entonces
hacemos las cuentas y nos queda menos
0.02 entre 2 y entonces aquí hay un
detalle muy importante que es que en
química las velocidades de reacción se
definen como un número positivo entonces
tenemos que agregar un signo menos por
acá para que la velocidad sea un número
positivo y de esta forma lo que nos
queda
0.01 molares por segundo muy bien
entonces ya calculamos la velocidad de
la reacción de dos formas la calculamos
como la velocidad de aparición de be y
también la calculamos como la velocidad
de desaparición de a pero podemos hacer
esto de una forma más general podemos
escribir que la velocidad de la reacción
es igual al cambio de las
concentraciones de a
/ el cambio en el tiempo pero hay que
recordar que si es el reactivo entonces
para que la velocidad nos quede como un
número positivo tenemos que colocar un
signo menos al principio nunca hay
porque en química la velocidad de las
reacciones queremos que sean números
positivos y como vimos aquí arriba si a
es el reactivo tenemos que poner por
aquí un signo menos ok entonces la
velocidad de la reacción es igual a
menos el cambio en la concentración del
reactivo entre el cambio en el tiempo y
eso a su vez es igual al cambio en la
concentración del producto entre el
cambio en el tiempo y por acá ya no
necesitamos un signo menos porque como
vimos aquí con b obtenemos una velocidad
de reacción positiva y entonces ya no le
tenemos que poner un signo menos muy
bien por aquí tenemos dos formas de
expresar la velocidad de la reacción que
es lo que habíamos visto arriba
pero lo escribimos de una forma un poco
más general y ahora vamos a ver otro
ejemplo vamos a ver este ejemplo tenemos
aquí una reacción un poco más complicada
tenemos aquí la ecuación balanceada de
penn tóxico de de nitrógeno que se
convierte en dióxido de nitrógeno y
oxígeno y digamos que el oxígeno se
forma con una velocidad de 9 por 10 a la
menos 6 molares por segundo entonces
cuál es la velocidad con la que se forma
dióxido de nitrógeno y bueno por si nos
fijamos en la ecuación balanceada por
cada átomo de oxígeno que se forme se
están formando cuatro átomos de dióxido
de nitrógeno entonces lo único que
tenemos que hacer es tomar la velocidad
de formación del oxígeno y multiplicar
la x 4 y eso lo que nos da es 3.6
por 10 al menos cinco molares por
segundo por lo tanto no2 de forma a una
velocidad cuatro veces mayor que o dos y
que podemos decir acerca del pnt óxido
de nitrógeno osea n 25 pues veamos por
aquí por cada átomo de oxígeno que se
forme estamos perdiendo dos átomos de
bent óxido de nitrógeno entonces
empezamos con la velocidad de formación
del oxígeno o sea 9 por 10 a la menos 6
y la multiplicamos por la relación molar
aunque ya tenemos un oxígeno por cada
dos de estos entonces tenemos que
multiplicar por 2 y además como estamos
perdiendo pent óxido de nitrógeno
tenemos que poner un signo de menos por
aquí y lo que nos queda es 1.8 por 10 a
la menos 5 molares por segundo así es
que el pent óxido de dyn
no desaparece dos veces más rápido de lo
que aparece el oxígeno bueno y ahora sí
vamos a pensar en la velocidad de la
reacción aunque entonces la velocidad de
nuestra reacción es igual a la velocidad
de formación del oxígeno a nueve por
diez a la menos 6 y lo podemos escribir
por acá como que la velocidad de la
reacción es igual al cambio en la
concentración del oxígeno entre el
cambio en el tiempo ahora qué pasa si
quisiéramos expresar la velocidad de la
reacción en términos de dióxido de
nitrógeno en ese caso por acá tenemos
que la velocidad de formación del
dióxido de nitrógeno en esta reacción es
de 3.6 por 10 a la menos 5 del 3.6 por
10 a la menos 5 y aquí nos tenemos que
preguntar cuál es el número por el cual
tengo que multiplicar
esta velocidad para obtener esta
velocidad de aquí que es la velocidad de
la reacción y entonces lo observamos
fijamente y pues sabemos que este número
es cuatro veces más grande que este
número por lo tanto tengo que
multiplicar por un cuarto y entonces por
acá si estamos pensando en el cambio de
concentración del dióxido de nitrógeno
entre el cambio en el tiempo para que la
velocidad sea la misma tenemos que
multiplicar por un cuarto bueno y
finalmente vamos a pensar en el pent
óxido de nitrógeno dijimos por acá que
el pent óxido de nitrógeno está
desapareciendo con una velocidad de
menos 1.8 por 10 a la menos 5 molares
por segundo
así es que otra vez porque el número
tengo que multiplicar a esta velocidad
de desaparición para obtener esta otra
velocidad lo observamos fijamente y
recordamos que
la velocidad de desaparición es dos
veces más grande que esta velocidad
entonces tenemos que multiplicar por un
medio pero además esta velocidad tiene
un signo negativo y la velocidad de la
reacción como ya hemos dicho antes está
definida como un número positivo
entonces tenemos que agregar un signo
menos por aquí lo que tenemos que
multiplicar por menos un medio y
entonces si esta multiplicación si nos
da 9 por 10 a la menos 6 aunque hay
entonces si quiero escribir la velocidad
de la reacción en términos del pnt óxido
de nitrógeno lo que tengo que hacer es
escribir por aquí el cambio en las
concentraciones de dióxido de nitrógeno
entre el cambio en el tiempo pero
multiplicarlo por menos un medio muy
bien entonces ya que averiguamos cómo
expresar nuestra velocidad de la
reacción podemos ponernos a observar
esta ecuación balanceada
por ejemplo aquí tenemos un 2 y
observemos adónde fue a dar este 2 por
aquí en la velocidad de la reacción
cuando la expresamos en términos del pnt
óxido de nitrógeno tenemos este 2 pero
por aquí en el denominador y luego
cuando expresamos la velocidad en
términos del dióxido de nitrógeno por
aquí en la ecuación balanceada tenemos
este 4 y en la velocidad de la reacción
ese 4 aparece pero en el denominador y
luego el oxígeno pues aquí tenemos un 1
y por aquí en la velocidad de la
reacción en términos del oxígeno pues
realmente aquí pudimos haber puesto un 1
entre 1 para mostrar que este 1 también
aparece en el denominador y que sea más
claro el patrón que siguen las
velocidades de reacción